quiero elaborar algunas ideas más
complejas basándome en lo que vimos en
el vídeo pasado acerca de la cruz
keynesiana y del gasto planeado agregado
ahorita voy a empezar ganando algunos
huequitos que dejamos en el vídeo pasado
y después vamos a pensar como esta
herramienta nos puede ayudar para el
pensamiento que iniciar entonces vamos a
hacer un pequeño repaso y para esto voy
a volver a construir la función de gasto
planeado agregado la voy a volver a
hacer pero con un poquito más de
precisión entonces vamos a ponerle por
aquí gasto planeado gasto planeado
agregado estoy aquí va a ser igual al
consumo de y usualmente lo vas a ver así
al consumo como función del ingreso
agregado menos los impuestos y quiero
dejar algo muy claro aquí no están
haciendo una multiplicación de consumo
agregado por el ingreso agregado menos
los impuestos más bien están diciendo
que el consumo está en función de esto
de acá así como cuando uno dice que f
está en función de x o sea si me das una
ye - t o sea si me das un ingreso
disponible entonces yo te puedo dar un
consumo estuve acá de hecho
de hecho o sea si quisieras más bien
lidiar con esto matemáticamente pues
tendrías que definir cuál es esta
función fábrica lo voy a escribir así y
para el siguiente paso vamos a ver cuál
es la expresión exacta hasta ahorita
sobre estamos diciendo que es una
función de consumo
arbitraria y está en función del ingreso
disponible entonces va a ser la función
de consumo más más la inversión planeada
que estamos poniendo que es constante
más el gasto de gobierno más la
exportación neta más la explotación neta
y hace algunos vídeos verdad hicimos
algunos modelos sencillos para la
función de consumo vamos a usar uno de
esos supongamos que nuestra función de
consumo supongamos entonces el consumo
agregado en función del ingreso
disponible o sea del ingreso menos los
impuestos supongamos que es igual a
cierto gasto autónomo más la propensión
marginal al consumo creo que ya no tengo
que cambiar colores porque ya vimos esto
antes más la propensión marginal al
consumo por el ingreso disponible por el
ingreso disponible entonces ahora puedes
ver que el consumo agregado
lo estamos definiendo estamos definiendo
en función del ingreso disponible y
entonces es lo que quiere decir esta
anotación de por acá entonces vamos a
sustituir esta expresión en función con
esta cosa verde de acá y entonces
podemos decir que el gasto planeado
agregado gasto planeado agregado es
igual a nuestra función de consumo
entonces es igual a dejado como con el
mismo amarillo es igual a
el consumo autónomo más la propensión
marginal al consumo por el ingreso
disponible que es el ingreso agregado
menos impuestos y claro tenemos otros
términos más la inversión planeada más
el gasto del gobierno más la exportación
neta más exportación neta y después
podemos simplificar esto un poquito para
dejar bien claro qué partes de acá son
constantes qué partes no son y qué
partes son función de ingreso verdad
ahorita con el fin de que esto sea más
sencillito verdad llegó hace algunos
vídeos estábamos platicando que los
impuestos podrían ser una función del
ingreso no en el mundo real si lo son
pero ahorita para este análisis vamos a
suponer que como la inversión la
inversión planeada que el gasto del
gobierno y la exportación neta como
todos estos factores vamos a suponer que
este término de acá también es constante
se supondremos que es
constante
constante entonces si suponemos que eso
de ahí es constante entonces podemos
multiplicar bueno aunque no lo sea
verdad que no sea constante pero lo que
quiero hacer es reescribir en términos
de ye entonces voy a distribuir el
segundo y entonces obtenemos a ver no
quiero seguir reescribiendo esto esta
parte de acá sería el gasto autónomo
sea uno porque más
por el ingreso agregado menos la
propensión marginal al consumo por los
impuestos más toda esta cosa de acá de
hecho debería copiarla y pegarla más
toda esta cosa pero de copiar
voy pegar
más todo esto de acá y eso de ahí es
igual a nuestro gasto planeado el gasto
planeado y ahora podemos pensar en esta
parte de acá verdad esta parte de acá es
lo que realmente está en función de o
vaya es lo único que está afectado por
el ingreso agregado entonces vamos a
poner en nuestros términos lo ponemos
nuestros términos entonces tenemos que
el gasto planeado es igual a la
propensión marginal al consumo por el
ingreso agregado por el ingreso agregado
este término de por acá que voy a meter
en una cajita y todo lo demás es una
constante entonces más este 60 que era
nuestro gasto autónomo menos 61 por t o
sea la propensión marginal al consumo
por t y estos dos son constantes según
nuestro análisis entonces todo esto es
constante más todo esto de acá
toda esta expresión ahora estoy acá
podría parecer una fórmula muy
complicada y sofisticada pero en
realidad es muy sencillita porque
estamos suponiendo para nuestra
discusión que todo esto que todo esto de
acá todo esto de por acá es constante
entonces si quisiéramos graficar esta
expresión se vería más o menos así vamos
a graficar la a ver esto es exactamente
lo que hicimos en el vídeo pasado nada
más estamos llenando los huequitos para
ver nuestra variable independiente va a
ser ingreso agregado o bien el producto
interno bruto como quieras verlo y luego
en nuestro eje vertical tenemos el gasto
gasto
ahí está entonces si quisiéramos
graficar esto la parte constante todo
esto de aquí si graficar amos mejor
dejar le pongo un nombre a todo esto le
voy a poner ve entonces aquí es donde
interpretaría el eje vertical estaría
por aquí digo podrían escribir todo pero
sería horrible mejor nada más le pongo
ve todo esto es b y luego tendríamos una
línea con pendiente hacia arriba claro
suponiendo que la pendiente es
dispositiva verdad es mayor que cero y
además es menor que 1 verdad no van a
gastar más que simples agregados o lo
van a gastar una fracción entonces esto
está entre 0 y 1 de esta forma
tendríamos que nuestra función de gasto
planeado es una línea que se vería más o
menos así entonces gasto planeado
agregado y bueno para pensar en términos
de la cruz keynesiana pues no podemos
tener una economía en equilibrio si la
producción si la producción agregada no
es igual al gasto agregado entonces para
pensar en todos los escenarios en los
cuales la economía está en equilibrio
vamos a dibujar una línea con 45 grados
porque cualquier punto en esta línea la
producción es igual al gasto
la producción es igual al gasto entonces
es una línea de 45 grados que se ve más
o menos así entonces es más o menos como
un repaso lo que está diciendo esto
realmente es que aquí o sea si tenemos
este gasto planeado entonces este punto
de acá es el punto de equilibrio es el
punto en el cual el gasto si el gasto es
igual a la producción y si ahora no se
digamos que por alguna razón en la
economía está produciendo más que ese
punto de equilibrio entonces la
producción que es esta línea de acá que
podemos verla como producción o como
gasto verdad es la línea donde son
iguales pero entonces esto de aquí es
donde la producción le está ganando al
gasto agregado o más bien al gasto
planeado agregado y entonces tenemos un
montón de inventario que se está
acumulando hay un buen inventario
acumulándose y entonces la inversión
actual o la verdadera sería más grande
que la inversión planeada por otro lado
si la producción está por abajo del
equilibrio entonces los gastos planeados
fueron más altos que la producción y
entonces la gente básicamente se va a
acabarlo
con esto tendríamos que la inversión
real va a ser menor que la inversión
planeada por qué pues porque justo ese
consumo de más se va a considerar como
una inversión negativa muy bien ahora la
razón por la cual volvía a plantear todo
esto verdad claro ahorita está un poco
más detallado pero la razón principal
por la cual hice esto es para ver que la
cruz que inician a más allá de
mostrarnos el punto de equilibrio
también nos va a servir para
preguntarnos desde un punto de vista que
iniciando cómo le podemos hacer para
cambiar ese punto de equilibrio o sea si
cambiamos da más la producción digamos
si la hacemos más alta
entonces los inventarios se acumulan y
las compañías van a querer bajar la
producción por otro lado si baja
entonces la gente quiere más se produce
más y vuelve al punto de equilibrio pero
qué sucede si el equilibrio no está en
nuestra opinión donde debería estar qué
sucede si la economía está muy por
debajo de su potencial muy por debajo
del empleo que puede tener entonces por
ejemplo qué tal que la economía que el
potencial de la economía así en un punto
óptimo de empleo está no sé quizás por
acá digo tal vez podemos debatir acerca
de dónde es el punto óptimo pero cómo
podemos moverlo hacia acá no podemos
simplemente aumentar la producción
porque eso haría que los inventarios se
acumulen verdad desde un punto de vista
keynesiano lo que queremos es desplazar
esta curva hay muchas formas en las
cuales podemos desplazar esta curva en
general podemos cambiar cualquiera de
estas variables por acá todo lo que
supusimos que era constante y eso
desplazaría la curva entonces no sé por
ejemplo el gobierno podría decir hey
sabes que lage estaba en cierto nivel
pero voy a hacer que esa g crezca vamos
a hacer que esa g la voy a cambiar a la
que ya estaba pero más más un pequeño
cambio en g
entonces agregan un incremento bueno
entonces ahora esto va a ser más grande
en este incremento de acá verdad y
entonces pues qué le sucede a la curva
pues justo se va a desplazar hacia
arriba por ese incremento vamos a ver
qué sucede cuando desplazamos la curva
hacia arriba por ese incremento deja lo
hago en rosa mexicano entonces si
desplazamos la curva hacia arriba en
delta g si la desplazamos en delta g
entonces va a acabar viéndose más o
menos así no estás cambiando la
pendiente verdad no estás cambiando esto
damos estás cambiando la intersección
estamos agregando del traje acá arriba y
sería ve la ve original más del traje
creo que lo podemos decir de esta forma
entonces nuestro nuevo gasto planeado se
vería más o menos así nuestro nuevo
gasto planeado se vería más o menos así
y esto está muy interesante verdad
porque ahora nuestro punto de equilibrio
el punto de equilibrio pues está en un
punto significativamente más alto de
hecho nuestro punto de equilibrio o más
bien nuestro cambio en el equilibrio
déjame ponerlo así el delta en la
producción de hecho creció más intenta
de la producción
fue más grande que nuestro cambio más
grande que nuestro cambio en el gasto
entonces parece que si valió la pena
claro si crees en este análisis de aquí
y visualmente la razón por la cual esto
sucedió es que esta línea tenía una
menor pendiente y entonces el nuevo
punto de intersección entre esa línea y
la línea de equilibrio la de pendiente
uno tenía que quedar más para fuera en
el siguiente vídeo vamos a ver que esto
también es consistente matemáticamente y
que todo tiene que ver con el efecto
multiplicador de hecho esa es la razón
por la cual algebraica mente estamos
obteniendo esto esto de que hay un mayor
cambio en la producción que el cambio
que el cambio incremental que se hace en
el gasto bueno esto se está poniendo
emocionante no te pierdas el próximo
vídeo